from the first moments of the new dlc
mission for final fantasy vii remake
it's clear intermission is mostly a
comedy
in jumps yuffie a teenage ninja secret
agent in one of the original game's
optional characters
and immediately her dangerous espionage
mission to infiltrate the evil shinra
corporation
is portrayed more like a kid goofing off
it's a vibe that really works for the
dlc
thanks to the fact that remake continues
to be great about establishing fun
eccentric characters ultimate material
to prove to our common enemy is not to
be trifled with
taking place in the middle of remake
story during the portion in which cloud
is separated from his compatriots
intermission follows yuffie as she works
to infiltrate shinra and steal a secret
weapon
on behalf of her homeland wutai the
mission is full of real-life danger
but yuffie approaches it with all the
seriousness of playing pretend
her excitement and enthusiasm is
infectious an interesting counterpoint
to the righteous anger at shinra
demonstrated by characters such as
barrett in the remake but the trouble
with intermission is that
this side story doesn't feel essential
to the bigger
final fantasy 7 picture sure the dlc
provides context and backstory for a
character that fans of the original
final fantasy vii
know will show up later in the story but
it does little to connect with remake's
larger plot
as it stands now yuffie's a fun
character to spend time with even if you
don't have
history with her from the first
iteration of final fantasy vii but the
dlc
still comes off as a tease for something
better down the road in ff7 remake's
next
installment as the name suggests
intermission feels like a half measure
to fill time
while we wait for the real show that's
not to say that intermission isn't fun
though
when yuffie is in combat which is pretty
damn often she's a blast to play
like all remakes characters yuffie has
her own distinct combat style
as a wu-tai ninja she packs a throwing
star that's good as a close-range melee
weapon
or at longer ranges choosing whether to
fight up close or from far away
allows you to control the flow of the
battle and mount
huge combos
you can get in close to wail on enemies
bounce back to create a gap then throw
the star for distant damage with
yuffie's elemental ninjutsu attacks
tap the triangle button and you can
retrieve your throne star not by drawing
it back to you but by sending yuffie to
it allowing you to quickly cover ground
and maneuver around the battlefield
partway through the first chapter of the
dlc yuffie is joined by
sonon a slightly older wutai operative
in combat
sonan acts as another means by which
yuffie can build combos
you can't control him directly but you
can issue orders like in remake
he also has a command called synergy
where yuffie and sonan execute their
abilities and attacks together
for big damage and added effects it's a
cool if fairly simple system
that provides another tool for combat
while keeping the focus on yuffie
and her specific style
it's in the dynamic between yuffie and
sonan where intermission is at its best
because yuffie is technically the senior
ninja despite her age
sonan defers to her judgment while
bouncing between feeling exasperated by
her overconfident antics
at trying to give her a little helpful
advice for her part
yuffie takes it all in stride she knows
how great a ninja she is
but she also never lets go of that air
of trying to appear cool
to whoever happens to be looking in her
direction we got this
she's a kid with incredible talent who's
still desperate to be taken seriously
while sonon is a protective older
brother type
looking for a middle ground between
annoying overbearance and risky
overindulgence
while the dynamic between yuffie and
sonon is an interesting one
it doesn't get tested or pushed very
much that's because the dlc never puts
the pair in especially
impactful situations over its 4 to 5
hour run time
the first chapter is mostly about
hanging around the sector 7 slums
killing time before heading to the
shinra building in chapter 2.
there's just not much in the way of
character conflict or
really conflict in general except for
dealing with the robots shinra
dispatches to try to stop you
[Music]
the same goes for what the story adds to
the overall tale of remake
intermission plops you in the middle of
sector 7 in the middle of that story
but your presence doesn't add any nuance
to what's already there
what is interesting are the moments
where yuffie and sonan have discussions
that give a wu-tai perspective on what
we've seen of midgar and shinra they
give us little looks into both yuffie's
character and the larger political
landscape
of final fantasy vii in a way that helps
you understand the world
a little better but these moments are
pretty few and far between
and while the character building for
yuffie is nice it's not super clear
what's to be gained
by revisiting this point in time or
these places
there's a big swing in this feeling
right at the end of the dlc
where intermission starts throwing deep
cut ff7 characters into the mix
it seems pretty clear that the idea here
is to bring in the wider ff7 universe
fleshed out in spin-offs like crisis
core and durge of cerberus
but the dlc doesn't provide any context
for what's going on
or who these people are again
intermission feels like a tease for
where things are going later on when
we're likely to get a more complete look
at some of these elements but for now it
mostly just makes yuffie's story
more confusing apart from the main story
intermission also adds some side content
to keep you busy
but it mostly just pads the runtime
there are a few combat challenges and
mini-games like remake's whack-a-box
providing youthy versions of things from
the vanilla game the big new addition is
fort condor a sort of light strategy
mini-game
in the broadest sense it's a board game
that mixes the spirit of chess
with the creature summoning of magic the
gathering you get a series of characters
you can place on your side of a game
board who then march toward your
opponent's side and try to destroy
their three forts your opponents can
also drop characters to fight yours
and which side wins a fight depends on a
rock paper scissors class system
fort condor is easy to pick up and can
be fun especially as you add new pieces
for more attack and defense options and
the ability to use some magic spells
during a match
but it's all pretty simplistic you don't
control the characters you just choose
where to put them
and the strategy is all about what
pieces you use and when
whoever has the game board that lets
them get pieces out faster
tends to win and there are just not a
lot of brainy options or strategies
that can help you win out over someone
with better stuff than you
with only a handful of matches to play
during your first run through the story
it also won't keep you busy for very
long goodbye
fortune goodbye pride the story of
intermission
fort condor and all the other content in
the dlc
suffer from the same problem they feel
pretty thin
not that an add-on chapter to a game
needs to be huge
but intermission takes place in one of
the hub areas of
ff7 remake and yet lacks meaningful
character interaction or side quests
to flesh out its world hanging out with
yuffie and sonan
is fun but while you have run-ins with a
number of important characters and key
moments the whole thing
adds little to remake as a whole in the
end
intermission is a pit stop a quick jaunt
into the gas station mini-mart of final
fantasy vii
to refuel grab a snack and get ready to
wait some more
with its fun combat and quirky character
moments it'll likely remind you of what
you like about ff7 remake
but it won't be enough to hold you over
that the gist of it boss
it sure is
[Music]
oh